mathieu trudel habite un logement
subventionné aux immeubles hsf depuis
cinq ans mais lui et sa femme devront
peut-être partir immeuble hsf tout comme
son partenaire milieu de vie tcc de
québec sont menacés de fermeture
après avoir été largué par leur assureur
à la suite d'un sinistre desjardins n'a
pas voulu renouveler le contrat
d'assurance de la copropriété
l'institution a proposé un sursis de
trois mois devant la difficulté du
syndicat a trouvé un nouvel assureur des
primes qui augmentent de 3 100 % des
franchises astronomique moins d'une
dizaine de compagnies accepte d'assurer
les grands immeubles au centre-ville
dans les groupes b zimmer bon vos choix
des franchises de cent mille deux cent
cinquante mille pour la maison martin
matte de québec qui prend soin de gens
souffrent de traumatismes crâniens
impossible de suivre la cadence
c'est sûr qu'avec ce qui s'est passé les
augmentations de primes sur lequel on
est
tu meures à confronter avec les
augmentations de franchise ça m'écoeure
complètement les organismes en péril au
niveau de sa survie et à court terme
nous on a on ne vit qu'avec les loyers
qui on peut pas les augmenter nous noyer
parce qu'on est régi pearl shq donc ça
va être la mort de deux organismes
ça va être la mort 2 h essais ont plus
d'ici avril 2022
les copropriétés doivent capitaliser un
fonds équivalant à la plus haute
franchise résultats de la loi 41 passé
l'an dernier 5 4 aux états deviennent
somme toute un peu leur propre assureur
quand on parle de franchise d'un quart
de million de dollars comme dans le cas
ici alors c'était à cash à chaque fois
qu'un sinistre jordy smith basse et les
critères qui doivent les semaines selon
l'avocat le gouvernement devra mettre un
plafond aux franchises
le gros du québec a le devoir de
démontrer son leadership en cette
matière parce qu'on est en train dans un
marché qui reste difficilement à ce rab
la situation se détériore sur le terrain
et ça prend absolument que le
gouvernement savait parce que sans aide
les résidents de cet immeuble pourrait
bien se retrouver à la rue ici marie
josée paquet comme ou radio canada
québec